[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis est de vous
retrouver pour une nouvelle édition de
parlement hebdo est le meilleur de la
semaine politique et parlementaire avec
vos organes mancini bonjour est notre
invité cette semaine et olivia grégoire
bonjour vous êtes député la république
en marche de paris est bienvenue à vous
et cette semaine la réforme ferroviaire
poursuivre son parcours parlementaire
elle était examiné en commission au
sénat la haute assemblée à modifier le
texte afin de tenter de répondre aux
inquiétudes des salariés
plus de 2600 amendement huit jours
d'examens l'assemblée nationale se
penche sur la loi agriculture et
alimentation qui vise notamment à
rééquilibrer les relations entre
producteurs et distributeurs
déverrouiller le verrou de bercy voilà
ce que propose un rapport parlementaire
rendu cette semaine ce dispositif
controversé d'un à l'administration le
monopole des poursuites pénales en cas
de fraude fiscale et faire passer le
budget des armées à 2% du pib c'est
l'objectif de la loi de programmation
militaire 2019 2025
elle était examinée cette semaine dans
l'hémicycle du sénat le gouvernement
défend un effort inédit
oui mais peut mieux faire répondre
sénateurs à cette semaine à les
cheminots votez donc contre la réforme
ferroviaire lors d'une consultation
interne et pendant ce temps là à cette
réforme était examiné au sénat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et les sénateurs de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire ont complété
cette réforme ferroviaire
si l'ouverture à la concurrence la
transformation de la sncf ou la fin du
recrutement aux statuts sont confirmés
les sénateurs ont apporté des garanties
notamment sur le transfert des cheminots
mode bio 169 amendements examinés en
commission pour enfin sceller le texte
du futur pacte ferroviaire parmi les
modifications apportées par les
sénateurs
la fin du statut des cheminots au 31
décembre 2019 une date qui correspond à
l'ouverture à la concurrence du réseau
ferroviaire
dans ce contexte d'ouverture les
cheminots était inquiet sur leurs
futures conditions de transfert les
sénateurs leur apporte des garanties des
salariés qui ont été transférés dans une
entreprise attributaire d'un marché
corps est perdu à un moment donné sncf
mobilité pourrait revenir s'il le
souhaite dans la sncf sncf mobilité dans
un délai compris entre 3 et 6 ans donc
c'est quelque chose c'est une nature à
rassurer les salariés ça offre l'espèce
de parachute sociale nouveauté également
les sénateurs veulent transformer la
branche gares et connexions aux filiales
et celle sieff réseau ce changement
garantir et une gestion plus autonome
des stations ferroviaires autre
amendement adopté le caractère
incessibles des titres de la future
société anonyme à capitaux publics
sur ce point le sénateur olivier jacque
à reste mesuré l'homo incessibilité ne
nous rassure pas totalement parce qu'une
loi peut casser l'incessibilité demain
et on a des inquiétudes dans le temps
long du ferroviaire sur la possibilité
demain devant notre patrimoine national
faut pas donner les clés du navire
comme on l'a fait sur les autoroutes
c'est une catastrophe absolue
le texte sera examiné en séance publique
du 29 mai au 5 juin prochain on les y
avoir on vient d'entendre le sénateur
socialiste olivier jacquin de dire que
le moins cessibilité ne le rassure pas
totalement parce que une loi demain veut
casser cette insensibilité
comment rassurer comment dissiper cette
inquiétude et garantir la non
privatisation de la sncf
je comprends les inquiétudes qui peuvent
s'exprimer ce qui est intéressant dans
ce que vient de dire le sénateur c'est
effectivement le temps long du
ferroviaire
je pense que le gouvernement a été assez
clair est d'autant plus clair que le
parlement aussi a suivi nous l'écrivons
dans le texte de loi le fait que jamais
on ne pourrait privatiser la sncf je
pense que le gouvernement et l'ensemble
des parlementaires
d'ailleurs de tous groupes sont assez
d'accord assez clair sur le fait que la
sncf c'est un patrimoine industriel et
un patrimoine français majeurs on a tous
d'ailleurs dans nos familles une
histoire avec la sncf il n'est
absolument pas question il n'a jamais
été question d'envisager une
privatisation il s'agit de réformer pour
mieux de sncf on l'a déjà dit on l'a
déjà exprimé je vais pas revenir dessus
mais dans le temps long du ferroviaire
peut-être faudra-t-il réassurer et
j'entends ce que dit le sénateur
mais ce qui est une évidence et ce sur
quoi il faut être très clair c'est que
le terme de pas de privatisation est
écrit noir sur blanc dans la loi
c'est dire à quel point on apprend la
conscience au sein du gouvernement comme
du parlement de la nécessité de
réassurer il ya un sujet qui me semble
important aussi qui a été cité sur le
sujet de gares et connexions
effectivement les sénateurs ont fait des
propositions assez intéressante
on marche un peu sur la tête quand on
regarde la réalité de la gestion des
gares et connexions vous avez une partie
de gares et connexions qui gère les gars
à proprement parler qui ont propriétaire
des bâtiments
ça n'est pas le même acteur qui est en
charge des verrières des quais etc
aujourd'hui en 2018 il faut
effectivement réunifier la gestion des
gares et je pense que les amendements du
sénat était assez intéressant à cet
effet ça fait partie des pistes que le
gouvernement et le parlement suivent une
question centrale c'est la dette de la
sncf edouard philippe reçoit les
syndicats 35 milliards d'euros seront
repris
par l'état est ce que cela veut dire que
le système ferroviaire sera l'équilibré
à la fin du quinquennat
alors déjà ça veut dire qu'il ya pas
d'effacement de la dette je suis désolé
de revenir dessus mais ça me semble
important vis-à-vis des contribuables
on ne peut pas pour des contribuables
pour lesquelles ça représente à peu près
500 euros par an et par foyer
d'investissement à la sncf dire alors
même que les contribuables connaissent
parfois des problèmes d'endettement
avant on efface je pense que c'est
important et que ses responsables au
plan politique
l'objectif effectivement c'est de
parvenir à l'équilibré
ça n'est pas rien à 1,35 milliard
d'euros edouard philippe le confirmera
dans les heures qui viennent vous venez
de le dire il reçoit les syndicats ce
matin l'objectif est effectivement de
parvenir alors pas uniquement avec
l'allègement substantiel de la dette
mais aussi avec une refonte une réforme
des services de parvenir à moins de
dettes et peut-être plus de bénéfices
pour rééquilibrer effectivement d'ici à
la fin du quinquennat
le but c'est optimiste ou réaliste je
pense que c'est un peu des deux 1 je
pense que je pense que c'est assez
réaliste il fallait choisir un des deux
terres mais j'ai confiance dans la sncf
dans sa direction mais aussi dans ses
agents pour prendre aussi le virage de
cette réforme
je pense que les agents et les les
travailleurs de la sncf sont aussi bien
conscient qu'il faut se moderniser sur
certains aspects et qu'il faut aussi de
nouvelles missions nouveau service pour
aussi avoir de nouveaux revenus pour
l'entreprise donc je pense que c'est
assez réaliste et je pense aussi que le
gouvernement prend ses responsabilités
c'était le sujet de démarrage la dette
c'est un sujet sur lequel il ya eu
beaucoup des changes aussi en équilibre
du statut des cheminots dans le cadre de
la concertation et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui gouvernement prend ses
responsabilités sur le sujet cette
semaine
l'assemblée nationale examine le projet
de loi agriculture et alimentation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dix mois après le lancement des états
généraux de l'alimentation la leur
agriculture et alimentation est donc
examiné cette semaine à l'assemblée
nationale plus de 2600 amendements
déposés sur ce texte
et parmi les sujets la question des
relations entre producteurs et grande
distribution
c'est l'objet de cet échange entre le
ministre de l'agriculture stéphane
travert et le député de la france
insoumise françois h
il s'agit que y ait une autre partie qui
entre dans le rapport de force et qui
viennent favoriser les plus faibles
aujourd'hui c'est à dire les producteurs
c'est-à-dire les agriculteurs contre les
plus fort et le plus fort aujourd'hui
c'est l'industrie agroalimentaire et
c'est la grande distribution nous nous
voulons que les filières et prennent des
engagements
nous voulons les responsabiliser ali
leïla le gouvernement veut que les
agriculteurs soient rémunérés au juste
prix en mettant la pression sur la
grande distribution pensez vous vraiment
pouvoir peser sur la grande distribution
oui nous pensons vous l'avez rappelé dix
mois d'échangés et de concertation vous
parlez d'un des piliers de la loi et
galim j'aimerais aussi qu'on parle du
second qui nous concerne nous tous les
concitoyens pour une alimentation saine
et durable ça me semble être un pilier
important aussi pour ce qui est des prix
je pensais d'ailleurs le vote des
premiers articles et notamment de
l'article 1 avec jean-baptiste moreau le
rapporteur on a témoigné il est
indispensable de rapprocher le prix de
vente de la réalité de ce que vivent les
agriculteurs et des coûts de production
à qui les intègre ça n'est pas rien non
plus que de renforcer la médiation dans
le secteur entre le l'alimentaire et
l'agricole il ya eu un certain nombre
d'amendements emportés par des collègues
comme matthieu orphelin sur
l'observatoire des prix et des marges
pour renforcer un peu son rôle et sa
supervision
le relèvement de 10% du seuil de revente
à perte
ça n'est pas rien non plus ce sont des
engagements extrêmement fort écrit dans
la loi
donc oui ça veut bien dire qu'on croit à
notre capacité non pas à rentrer dans un
bras de fer mais en réalité à assurer un
juste prix de revient pour les
agriculteurs qui sont aujourd'hui dans
des situations économiques sur
lesquelles on ne peut pas rester aveugle
ou sourd c'était un engagement fort du
gouvernement de regarder le sujet depuis
des mois nous prenons aujourd'hui des
dispositions que nous écrivons dans la
loi ans
tiers de prix et l'objectif est
effectivement que nos agriculteurs
soient rémunérés un juste prix et ne
subissent plus un certain nombre de
pratiques commerciales de la grande
distribution qui juste met à mal bien
sûr nos agriculteurs mais aussi la
qualité de notre alimentation de
l'anneau de celle de nos enfants et je
pense que c'est important de rappeler le
lien entre le travail que nous faisons
sur le prix sur les marges pour une
agriculture des agriculteurs qu'ils
soient mieux rémunérés pour des produits
de qualité
jusqu en fait moi on rémunère - la
qualité je suis donc l'objectif est de
préserver une agriculture de qualité et
de donner aussi des objectifs forts en
matière de restauration collective par
exemple d'ici à 2022 avec atteindre à
peu près 50% de produits de qualité de
la belle et bio dans la restauration
collective des engagements extrêmement
fort je rappelle juste parce que c'est
quand même assez important
c'était un engagement extrêmement claire
du président de la république pendant la
campagne et qu'en un an le projet de loi
est aujourd'hui en hémicycle en vogue
depuis sept semaines vote solennel la
semaine prochaine des paroles aux actes
il y aura peut-être des choses à amender
à améliorer en attendant on prend là
aussi nos responsabilités et on met dans
la loi un certain nombre de dispositions
fortes sur les prix
on inverse en a moins en un mot la
construction des prix et ça n'est pas
rien on a bien compris cette question
des prix mieux rémunérés évidemment le
producteur mais les prix à la
consommation ne risque-t-il pas
d'augmenter ce n'est pas ça n'est pas
guidé l'idée c'est de demander en
l'occurrence à la grande distribution et
aux revendeurs eux d'assurer la juste
rémunération des agriculteurs sans pour
autant augmenter les prix de vente et
les prix pour les consommateurs donc non
l'objectif c'est de travailler sur
l'amont de la chaîne et pat les
consommateurs le subissent en aval c'est
pas l'idée il serait vigilant et
justement sur ces marges de la grande
distribution
oui on sera vigilant et sur les marges
mais pas uniquement on sera vigilant sur
les marges sur les prix et sur les
pratiques
le pot de miel par exemple les pratiques
frauduleuses le made in france écrit sur
des pots de miel qui sont fabriqués en
chine
ça peut paraître anodin c'est 80% de la
production de miel qui est concerné en
france donc on sera vigilant oui sur les
prix mais aussi sur les pratiques
commerciales pour qu'on dise la vérité
aux consignes aux concitoyens lorsqu'ils
achètent un produit s'il est fabriqué en
france ou pas ça peut paraître encore
une fois des sujets assez connexes c'est
des vrais sujets importants les
pratiques trompeuses au plan commercial
allez on en vient cette fois aux verrous
de bercy ce mécanisme presque
centenaires aujourd'hui controversé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
faut-il faire sauter le verrou de bercy
une mission parlementaire s'est penché
sur ce mécanisme elle remettait cette
semaine ses conclusions et pour elle il
faut vider ce verrou de sa substance
faire évoluer le système de lutte contre
la fraude fiscale et étendre le champ
d'action de la justice aurélie darblade
juillet rusti le verrou de bercy
pourrait bien disparaître c'est en tout
cas la principale proposition du rapport
parlementaire sur les infractions
fiscales aujourd'hui en cas de fraude le
mécanisme du verrou s'enclenche le fisc
saisit alors la commission des
infractions fiscales qui renvoie ou non
le dossier vers la justice si la
décision de poursuite seul le ministère
du budget peut porter plainte
le rapport veut en finir avec ce
monopole trop opaque et préconise le
remplacement du verrou par un tandem
administrations fiscales justice pour
développer une vraie réponse pénale
les fruits du contrôle fiscal qui est
très très actif aujourd'hui en france 1
qui produit 20 milliards d'euros de
droits d'impôts et de pénalités tous les
ans continue
à prospérer de cette manière là et tout
en assurant quand même cette liberté du
procureur donc on institue un travail
croisés et en institutionnalisant
notamment des points de contacts
réguliers entre les parquet et
l'administration fiscale le fisc et les
différents parcs et se réunir et dans
des comités pour examiner les dossiers
de fraudeurs des dossiers sélectionnés
selon des critères fixés par la loi
l'état verrait alors son pouvoir
diminuer au profit de celui des
magistrats et du parlement le ministre
du budget gérald darmanin s'est montré
hostile
un tel changement survol l'état en ne
payant pas son impôt c'est à l'état de
décider s'il souhaite ou pas porter
plainte est normal que les clés soient
confiées au parlement à l'autorité
judiciaire blé pour réduire un petit peu
l'opacité alors monsieur darmanin il va
défendre son administration et nous nous
défendons le rôle des parlements et
c'est pour les membres de la mission et
les ministres débattront de l'avenir du
verrou avec l'arrivée dans l'hémicycle
de la loi sur la fraude fiscale d'ici la
fin de l'année
il est temps de revoir ce dispositif qui
date de 1920 alors un il était temps 2
je me rappelle il ya quelques mois lors
du projet de loi de finances de
l'émotion autour du verrou de bercy
lorsque nous avions dit qu'une mission
était en cours les oppositions nous
avait un peu temps c'est ce qui manque
vous savez pas où la mission allait
atterrir et ben vous voyez la mission a
atterri et moi je suis à l'écouté
l'atterrissage la mission d'information
je voulais quand même partagé une chose
avec vous qu'on sait pas forcément à
cette heure c'est que c'est la première
fois depuis bientôt un an que moi je
suis parlementaire et que j'essaie
tonnard que l'ensemble des groupes et
les parlementaires peu importe les
origines politiques sont d'accord sur
les conclusions d'un rapport
parlementaire ça n'est pas rien ça veut
dire que deux eric coquerel à charles de
courson en passant par la république en
marche au tour d'emilie carew mais aussi
du président diard nous sommes tous
d'accord avec les conclusions qui ont
été remises
l'idée simple il ya à peu près 15 mille
dossiers instruits au plan fiscal par an
mil a river au pénal jean louis
bourlanges à une expression je trouve
sympathique à un tuyau de distillation
entre les quinze mille et mille
l'objectif c'est de croiser comme l'a
dit émilie cariou à juste titre les
expertises à la fois du fisc et des
tribunaux s'il y a que le fis
ce qu'on n'est pas assez efficient et on
le voit aujourd'hui s'il n'y a que les
tribunaux on manque d informations
fiscales donc il faut qu'on ait une
dynamique croisés l'objectif est assez
simple c'est d'aller chercher les gros
fraudeurs
parce qu'aujourd'hui il faut qu'on se
concentre sur ceux dont la pratique
quotidienne et la fraude fiscales donc
sur la forme je voudrais quand même dire
que ça fait plaisir aussi de voir que
sur certains sujets qui sont techniques
on arrive à bosser dans l'apaisement et
on arrive à trouver des solutions gérald
darmanin s'y opposent eh bien écoutez
c'est le jeu je pense que c'est
intéressant et nous allons avoir la
discussion c'est le jeu nous sommes le
parlement nous ne soulevons la décision
du noir devant des échanges mais je
pense qu'il est très important comme le
disait le président que c'est pas donné
les clés du verrou de bercy aux
parlementaires c'est faire en sorte que
les parlementaires par l égide de la loi
puisse revoir et amender les critères de
gravité pour pouvoir entamer une
procédure pénale c'est extrêmement
important et je pense qu'aujourd'hui ça
fait partie aussi des des requêtes que
les parlementaires hongrois porter
légitimement on va passer à la loi de
programmation militaire 2009 2025
étaient au menu de la séance cette
semaine au sénat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
objectif de cette loi faire passer le
budget des armées de 34,2 milliards à 50
milliards d'ici sept ans pour atteindre
2% du pib
la majorité sénatoriale reconnaît
l'effort du gouvernement
mais on est encore loin du compte c'est
en tout cas ce que dit christian cambon
le sénateur les républicains président
de la commission des affaires étrangères
et de la défense
nous manquons de visibilité sur le
rythme des livraisons d'équipements ou
sur les infrastructures puisque nous
devons nous contenter d'objectifs assez
lointain 2025 2030 sans les points de
passages annuels
ce point est d'autant plus crucial que
la lpm ne couvre qu'une partie des
besoins
il manque un milliard et demi d'euros de
crédits sur les infrastructures en 2025
60 % des installations de la défense ou
casernes notamment seront encore dégradé
les recrutements nous paraissent trop
faible et trop lent 450 recrutements
chaque année pour des besoins estimés
par la commission à 2500 par an on est
encore loin du compte
encore loin du compte dit christian
cambon vous venez de l'entendre est ce
que ce projet de loi est assez ambitieux
est ce qu'ils répondent aux besoins
urgents de l'armée française oui ou
c'est c'est dans le jeu politique chacun
est dans son rôle
monsieur cambon sénateur les
républicains estiment que ça n'est pas
suffisant
bon moi j'ai quand même écouter pour
partie des discussions au sénat
l'effort est quand même salué au plan
budgétaire c'est un effort qui est assez
inédit et effectivement on a aussi un
certain nombre de contraintes de
dépenses publiques
on raisonne pas sans contraintes donc on
étale effectivement l'augmentation du
budget mais elle est quand même majeurs
et sur des sujets par exemple vous
parlez d'immédiateté sur les opex les
opérations extérieures
on passe de 450 millions d'euros à plus
d'un milliard et d'un milliard à 1 donc
on fait des efforts substantiels sur un
certain nombre de sujets et on on
sacralise on sanctifie un certain nombre
de budgets sur les familles sur les
équipements aussi des soldats du 2e au
quotidien donc rien n'est jamais parfait
allez un effort inédit il est acté on va
mettre en oeuvre ce qui est sûr c'est
que ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui en
matière de défense
c'est pas les 5 ou les dix dernières
années qu'on a fait cet effort
budgétaire
alors qui va financer le service
universel les sénateurs ont confirmé que
ce ne serait pas l'armée ça ne serait
pas pris sur le budget des armées
on avait on n'a jamais d'ailleurs
envisagé que le service national
universel sur lequel nous sommes encore
en train de réfléchir à la fois sur les
modalités comme le financement ferait
partie de la lpm donc moi je suis
absolument pas surprise ne pas trouver
le ceni dans la lpm
il ya aujourd'hui des parlementaires qui
travaillent pour le gouvernement sur sur
ce sujet on trouvera des pistes de
financement mais vous savez moi j'ai
galéré comme je ne sais pas c'est une
professeur emmanuel c'est une promesse
donc connaissant un peu emmanuel macron
je n'ai aucun doute sur le fait qu'elles
seraient mises en oeuvre
moi je viens de l'entreprise
réfléchissons dans le bon ordre
c'est quoi l'objectif du service
national universel quelles seront ses
missions et ensuite on dégagera les
masses budgétaires on saura combien il
faut pour le financer et ensuite on
trouvera les masses budgétaires je vais
pas commencer par vous donner un chiffre
alors même que je ne sais pas exactement
quelles seront les missions qu'elles
seront le nombre de jeunes concernés
puisque je ne suis pas dans la mission
et je siège présent cette commission
donc je pense que là aujourd'hui on est
dans une période d' expertise a
partiellement on aura défini les
contours
on pourra trouver les hommes budgétaire
et si vous trouvez les moyens on les
trouvera allez c'est l'heure de
retrouver à un autre partenaire
politique est du figaro.fr
[Musique]
et ces tortures berda à bonjour qui nous
a rejoint aujourd'hui jean marion
bonjour janullah toujours olivia gregor
hauts revenus ensemble ce matin sur une
polémique qui a agité le gouvernement
cette semaine sur la baisse supposée des
aides sociales à l'emploi qui était
évoquée par le ministre de l'économie
bruno le maire dimanche dernier il était
depuis recadré par agnès buzyn sa
collègue de la santé et même son
colocataire à bercy le ministre du
budget gérald darmanin
est ce que le selon vous cette sortie
bruno le maire il s'agit d'un couac d'un
ballon d'essai ou d'une stratégie de
personnel du ministre de l'économie
alors j'ai essayé en préparant cette
émission de me mettre dans le cerveau de
bruno le maire un j'ai pas réussi et
deux je ne sais pas exactement ce qu'il
avait en tête s'y était préparé c'était
spontané vous savez moi je n'aime pas la
post rationalisation je sais pas ce qui
est sûr c'est que ça et mus a entraîné
un certain nombre de discussions et de
mise au point assez clair d'ailleurs aux
questions au gouvernement
daniel bizien vous l'avait dit et gérald
darmanin jeu on peut couper les phrases
et les expressions moi ce que j'ai
entendu c'est si et seulement si en
l'occurrence la croissance est au rendez
vous et donc aussi que grâce à nos
réformes économiques et fiscales on
arrive à soutenir cette croissance et à
relancer l'emploi dans notamment
l'emploi marchand dans les entreprises
on peut logiquement espérer qui aura
peut-être moins besoin de prestations
sociales en termes de masse voilà ce que
moi j'ai compris bon j'ai pas entendu
parler de suppression des aides sociales
et d'ailleurs j'ai plutôt entendu gérald
darmanin et agnès buzyn confirmé qu'
aucune aide sociale personnalisés ne
seraient concernés toucher ou même
raboter ce mot que je déteste dans les
années qui viennent donc je pense que
non il ya aussi un jeu ou peut-être
qu'on a mal compris et où que on a prêté
des intentions qui sont pas forcément
celles de bruno le maire en revanche que
je porte aussi comme jugement c'est que
c'est important on aime la république en
marche on essaie d'avoir quand même un
discours assez lucide assez cash comme
on dit aujourd'hui sur les aides aux
entreprises quand gérald darmanin
répondu en précisant un que les aides
sociales personnalisée ne serait
absolument pas au go à l'ordre du jour
mais deux qui on avait le droit d'ouvrir
des réflexions sur un certain nombre
d'aidés notamment des deux entreprises
monsieur rapporteuse spéciale
entreprises
je ne m'interdis pas et je comprends les
réflexions des ministres ce qu'il ya
c'est qu'aujourd'hui ouvrir un sujet on
a le sentiment que c'est l'arbitré
on ouvre un sujet sur les aides aux
entreprises c'est aujourd'hui à peu près
140 milliards d'euros 140 milliards
d'euros c'est dix fois le budget du
ministère de l'intérieur par exemple
mans et si on met les niches fiscales et
compagnie on peut atteindre des chiffres
qui sont plutôt du double hauteur de 300
milliards d'euros
gérald darmanin annonce par exemple
qu'on peut envisager dans le quinquennat
de diminuer de 5 milliards d'euros les
aides à certaines entreprises
c'est assez peu en termes de masse par
rapport à la masse globale et
deuxièmement qu'est ce qu'on est en
train de faire on n'est pas en train
d'envisager de couper des aides on met
tous les chantiers sur la table on
travaille sur les taxes de production on
travaille avec le pacte sur
l'amélioration de la fiscalité des
entreprises donc ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'on ne se prive d'aucune
réflexion en matière d' être social
personnalisé on a refermé le dossier
pour les aides aux entreprises ont
louvre on va parler d'un autre dossier
alors sur lequel la majorité c'est
encore un peu fracture et cette semaine
c'est le cas de mariam pouls de tous est
présidente de l'unef à la sorbonne
l'unef paris iv qui est apparue voilée à
la télévision les différentes voix qui
se sont élevées dans la majorité avec
différentes tonalités
d'un côté on à aurélien tâche et qui a
défendu le droit de cette jeune femme à
porter le voile et la compatibilité
entre ce vêtement islamique et ses
fonctions de représentation et il ya
d'autres voies un peu plus ferme au sein
de la majorité
est ce que vous regrettez l'absence
d'identité commune de la république en
marche de la macro ni plus généralement
sur ces question d'islam de laïcité
non je ne regrette pas la relative
polyphonie sur ces sujets moi j'ai
démarré en tant que porte-parole ya un
an avec une étiquette de godillots je
reviens aujourd'hui et j'ai on a une
étiquette deux ans mais vous avez de la
polyphonie de la variété de la diversité
dans votre groupe
mais vous savez quoi moi c'est ce que je
trouve intéressant dans notre groupe
ça veut pas dire que ce soit des
oppositions interhumaine frontale
violente etc
chacun exprime son point de vue on est
un nom de démarrage du quinquennat du
président il ya un certain nombre de
sujets sur lesquels ses prises de
positions vont être précises et
approfondies notamment sur ces sujets de
laïcité dans l'émoi dans les années qui
viennent
moi je trouve sain dans un groupe
parlementaire
que chacun s'exprime je trouve sain
aussi et je le dis puisqu'un
indirectement vous me demandez mon avis
en tout cas que j'ai pas peur de le
donner que des gens comme bruno julliard
ou que julien dray et rappelait 2,3
évidence je n'étais pas militant à
l'unef
il ya 15 ans ou 20 ans mais je sais pour
l'avoir vu le combat de l'unef moi
j'étais à nanterre notamment où je les
ai vus pour la laïcité pour la
neutralité sur ces questions de laïcité
et c'est vrai quand j'écoute bruno
julliard ou julien dray je me demande un
peu si l'unef s'est pas perdue dans
certains de ces combats troisième et
dernière question mercredi en conseil
des ministres les principales mesures de
l'avant constitutionnel ont été adoptés
à savoir une baisse de 30% du nombre de
parlementaires une instauration de 15%
de proportionnelle et l'interdiction de
faire plus de trois mandats consécutifs
maximum
est-ce que selon vous gérard larcher le
sénat de droite va jouer le jeu
ou est ce que on va devoir être amenés à
aller vers le référendum pour faire
passer cette réforme
je sais pas là aussi j'ai essayé mais
j'arrive pas à rentrer dans la tête de
gérard larcher décidément plus moi ce
que je vois dedans cette réforme c'est
que tout est fait d'eux des deux côtés
et aux côtés des chambres et par le
gouvernement et aussi par le président
pour qu'on trouve une solution de
consensus et qui est un accord commun et
d'ailleurs on s'inspire d'un certain
nombre de pratiques mises en oeuvre par
le sénat devait pas être technique mais
sur les amendements sans rapport avec le
texte tous les amendements non normatif
on prend des pratiques du sénat donc il
ya on partage les bonnes expériences et
je pense que ça démontre aussi la bonne
volonté du côté des deux chambres ya une
chose que je voudrais dire sur cette
réforme parce que elle est assez
complexe elle est en trois blocs les
trois blocs se tienne c'est extrêmement
important sur le premier bloc
constitutionnel déjà je voudrais quand
même dire que ça fait des années que
tout le monde en parle que tout le monde
appelle de ses voeux ses réformes
notamment au plan de l'indépendance de
la justice et que personne ne l'a fait
on a le courage de le faire la seule
chose que je veux ajouter c'est ne nous
ne loupons pas le débat l'enjeu c'est
moins parlementaire pour un parlement
beaucoup plus efficace gagner du temps
ça veut dire juste commencé à arrêter
d'en perdre et ce sera le mot de la fin
merci les jaguars merci à tulle
ainsi marion merci à tous de nous avoir
suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]